I have today's forecast for you I put
these [ __ ] snakes on this
[ __ ] plane
it's my duty please sit booty oh [ __ ]
why no country I ever heard of there's
the interest in what what English
[ __ ] do you speak it yes wanna
did say what again I dare you I double
dare you [ __ ] say what one more
goddamn time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're under arrest you shut your face
if we want to hear you talk
okay guys let's get this frog in the
bird teaches ain't supposed to touch
students I'm not a teacher I'm the new
basketball coach my job is to keep you
out of harm's way [ __ ]
I am you man
just to be honest I recognize the
council has made a decision but given
that it's a stupid-ass decision I have
elected to ignore it if there is someone
like me in the world and I'll make one
end of the spectrum couldn't there be
someone else opposite me of the other
hand and I will strike down upon thee
with great vengeance and furious anger
those who attempt to poison and destroy
my brothers we're going to pull together
and we're gonna find a way to get out
first we're gonna
[Music]